thanks to brilliant for sponsoring a
section of this video if you were to
imagine a planet-wide hell
venus would be pretty close its
atmosphere is 90 times thicker than the
earth's
sulfuric acid rains down in the middle
atmosphere and surface temperatures are
a scorching
464 degrees celsius pretty much
everywhere on the planet's surface from
the equator to the poles
day to night you would last longer on
mars without a spacesuit than you would
on venus
with a spacesuit we are constantly told
that a doubling of the earth's
atmospheric co2 concentration will
result in a warming of between one and a
half and four and a half degrees
celsius practically that means that if
we add an extra one and a half trillion
tons of co2 to our atmosphere
we can expect that the earth will warm
between one and a half and four and a
half degrees c
but assuming a warming of say two
degrees celsius for every one and a half
trillion tons of co2 in its atmosphere
venus with approximately 463 quadrillion
tons of co2 in its atmosphere
should be approximately 635 000 degrees
warmer than the earth
rather than the puny 430 degrees warmer
that we observe it to be
gentlemen that's not acceptable to work
out why this is we need to look at why
venus is the temperature it is
work out why venus is so cold first of
all we quickly need to define a unit
called a kelvin
which is exactly the same as a degree
celsius except
absolute zero is zero kelvin rather than
minus 273.15 ish degrees
celsius kelvin is a measurement of
absolute temperature or in other words
how hot something is
relative to absolute zero on this scale
venus has an average surface temperature
of about 740 kelvin
while the earth has an average surface
temperature of about 288 kelvin
or in other words venus is a little less
than three times as hot
as the earth now is that what we'd
expect
well to answer that we had to look at
where earth and venus get their energy
from
which is of course the sun venus orbits
the sun
at just less than three quarters the
distance that the earth orbits
the amount of solar energy received at a
given distance from the sun is given
by an inverse square law as you get
close to the sun you receive much more
energy because we can measure how much
solar energy we receive here on earth
about 1 370 watts per square meter
we can work out the total energy output
of the sun and thus the amount of energy
that venus receives per square meter
this turns out to be almost twice as
much as the earth receives
about 2 600 watts per square meter so
shouldn't venus be twice as hot as the
earth then
about 560 570 kelvin
well not quite a planet reaches a
certain temperature when the amount of
energy it receives matches the amount of
energy it radiates back into space
in a process we call black body
radiation the equation
governing how much black body radiation
it emits per square meter
is called the stefan boltzmann law now
if we set this equal to the amount of
energy a planet receives
per square meter from the sun and
account for the fact that the planet
only receives this energy on its day
side but emits energy
all over all the time we get an equation
for the predicted temperature of the
planet
technically called the planetary
equilibrium temperature
plugging in the amount of energy that
venus receives from the sun into this
equation
we get a planetary equilibrium
temperature of about 327 kelvin
or 54 degrees celsius and this is the
temperature we observe the top of
venus's atmosphere to be
the surface however is approximately 400
kelvin hotter
which tells us that atmospheric
processes must be causing the difference
but there are two components to those
processes firstly
venus's atmosphere is incredibly cloudy
in fact only about 10
of the energy that hits the top of the
atmosphere reaches the surface
compare that to earth where about 75 of
incident light reaches the surface
accounting for this effect what we call
the planetary albedo a measure of how
reflective the planet is
the planetary equilibrium temperature
plummets to a mere 162 kelvin
or minus 111 degrees celsius secondly of
course there is the greenhouse effect
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
prevents blackbody radiation from
leaving the planet
this means that less energy is radiated
to space while the same amount of energy
comes in from the sun
causing the temperature to rise
according to our analysis
this greenhouse effect is responsible
for about 560 kelvin of
warming the difference between the
planetary equilibrium temperature that
we just worked out
and the observed surface temperature of
venus so let's bring all of this
together
venus has approximately 200 000 times as
much co2 in its atmosphere as the earth
did before the industrial revolution
and we're told that if we double the
amount of co2 in the earth's atmosphere
so add the amount that was in the
atmosphere before the industrial
revolution again
that we will experience about two
degrees celsius of warming
but our analysis on venus indicates that
it experiences
maybe 0.0028
kelvin of warming for every earth's
worth of co2 in its atmosphere
so why is it then that earth co2 is
pound per pound meant to cause
more warming than venus co2
the simple answer is that it isn't
this is the problem kind of
if you doubled the amount of co2 in the
earth's atmosphere but kept absolutely
everything else
the same the planet would warm by about
one degree
celsius the reason this is so much more
than the number we just worked out for
venus
is because the greenhouse effect isn't a
linear process
starting with a planet that has no co2
in its atmosphere at all
each earth's worth of co2 about one and
a half trillion tons that you add to its
atmosphere will cause a great deal of
warming
so will the second keep adding trillions
of tons of co2 however and each
successive contribution will cause less
and less
warming venus has got so much co2 that
you could probably remove a significant
fraction of its atmosphere and its
average temperature
wouldn't drop by that much it should be
noted however that on earth we are very
much down here towards the start of this
graph
co2 causing warming is a non-linear
process sure
but if you add co2 to the atmosphere
right now you're still causing basically
as much additional warming
as if there were no co2 present to begin
with because it's still
such a small part of our atmosphere
however the reason that doubling co2
concentration in the earth's atmosphere
is meant to cause
between one and a half and four and a
half degrees of warming not just
one degree is because the co2 has
backup it has family any warming caused
by an increase in atmospheric co2
also triggers a bunch of knock-on
effects a bunch of
feedbacks arguably the most important of
which is an increase in the amount of
water vapor held in the earth's
atmosphere
warm air holds more water and water
vapor is a really potent greenhouse gas
these feedbacks are actually predicted
to cause most of the warming associated
with a doubling and atmospheric co2
they're also responsible for most of the
uncertainty around
how much extra warming will take place
the co2 in its own will probably cause
about one degree of warming
but the feedbacks that could be an extra
half a degree of warming it could be an
extra
three and a half degrees of warming this
stuff is really hard to model the
takeaway here is that venus is as cold
as it is
one because it has thick clouds that
block out most sunlight and two
because the greenhouse effect is
non-linear and venus is
so much further down the line than the
earth that any comparison between the
two planets is
basically meaningless venus not having
feedbacks especially those involving
water vapor
also means that comparing the effect of
co2 pound per pound on the two planets
just doesn't work in conclusion venus is
as cold as
it's supposed to be according to basic
physics
now let's try and focus on keeping earth
as cold as it's
supposed to be we already have one
experiment in the solar system showing
the effects of lots of co2 in a planet's
atmosphere
we really don't need a second
my target audience for these videos is
people who like to question things
people who like to improve their
understanding of the world around them
through interesting examples and if that
sounds like you
i think you might really like brilliant
who have kindly sponsored this video
brilliant is a website and app that lets
you develop skills in maths
science and computer science through
solving problems it's designed to be a
great resource to support classroom
learning
but also be a standalone educational
resource for curious adults
they have courses on a huge variety of
subjects in stem including
calculus astrophysics neural networks
and so
many more crucially these professionally
written courses are based on solving
problems rather than memorizing facts
they also have daily challenges to keep
your brain cells engaged and expose you
to a constantly evolving set of
interesting subjects
i can personally recommend brilliant
because i've used it to brush up on my
chemistry
and my quantum mechanics knowledge and i
honestly really enjoyed my time spent
using the website the
assets of each course are beautifully
illustrated and the problems are really
well thought out
you can check out brilliant for free
right now and if you'd like to get
access to their courses then you can get
yourself
a premium subscription or of course you
can gift a premium subscription to
someone maybe a student in your life
and you can do that at brilliant.org
simon clark
the first 200 people to go to that link
will get a sweet 20
discount thank you so much to brilliant
for sponsoring this video
and for continuing to support this
channel thank you so much for watching
the video
i really hope you enjoyed this one which
was inspired by a bunch of comments that
were left under some of my older climate
change videos
basically going venus so it's a pretty
simple argument to debunk if you like
but i hope this was interesting and
hopefully showcased a little bit of how
climate physics works in action as
always if you did enjoy the video please
do pop it a like and let me know what
you thought down there in the comments
here's some recommended doing next
and that just leaves me to say thank you
again for watching i really hope you
enjoyed it and i will see you
in the next one
[Music]